mean this is this is mixing the red pill
in with the Conspiracy Theory with like
crypto but like they've been I mean we
know we all know this [__] they've been
trying to control the global population
for a [__] long time now and it's
really messed up they started with the
African-American Community let's let's
not even talk about all these freaking
vaccines and I'm not talking about the
ones that happened recently I'm talking
about way back in the day that they were
infecting people they were literally
infecting people with like tuberculosis
and all this crazy ass crap to get
people sick to them kill them off and
then I mean even the Germans the Germans
were using these these machines and
stuff on um the Jewish people as well as
Gypsies and people that they didn't like
so they would imagine like they make
their own Planned Parenthood you come in
there they would have like a basically a
radiation machine kind of a set like
this they would turn it on and you would
be standing in line and they you
couldn't have kids anymore and that [__]
is real the Germans did that